Producing a podcast might seem pretty straightforward to some, but in reality, it involves a lot of behind the scenes tasks that make it more involved than it appears. For each Casefile episode, extensive research, writing and recording are only the beginning, and that's not to mention the promotional aspects such as marketing and merchandising. If you run an e-commerce business, you can relate to the amount of work it takes to produce something great. Like us, you want to optimise your workflow and reduce costs. ShipStation is the multi-carrier shipping solution that integrates wherever you sell online. When you optimise your shipping process and connect to a network of expert partners, you
对一些人来说，制作播客似乎相当简单，但实际上，它涉及许多幕后工作，使其比看起来要复杂得多。对于每一集《Casefile》，大量的研究、撰写和录音仅仅是个开始，更不用说市场营销和商品推广等宣传方面的工作了。如果你经营一家电子商务企业，你就能体会到制作出色的产品需要付出多少努力。像我们一样，你希望优化工作流程并降低成本。ShipStation 是一款多承运商运输解决方案，可与你在线销售的任何平台集成。当你优化运输流程并连接到专家合作伙伴网络时，你
reclaim valuable time for what truly matters – growing your business. Casefile team member Paulina has just signed up to ShipStation for her Shopify store and already can't imagine life without it. It was so easy to get started and she loves how everything she needs is in one simple interface. She can keep track of all her orders and automate tasks she used to have to complete manually, saving her heaps of time in the process. And Paulina isn't the only one. Over 130,000 companies have grown their e-commerce
就能收回宝贵的时间，专注于真正重要的事情——发展你的业务。Casefile 团队成员保琳娜（Paulina）刚刚为她的 Shopify 商店注册了 ShipStation，现在已经无法想象没有它的生活了。上手非常容易，她很喜欢所有需要的功能都在一个简单的界面中。她可以跟踪所有的订单，并自动化处理以前必须手动完成的任务，从而节省了大量时间。保琳娜并不是唯一一个这样的人。超过 13 万家公司通过 ShipStation 发展了他们的电子商务
business with ShipStation. And 98% of companies who stick with ShipStation for a year become customers for life. Make shipping the easy part of having an online store. You have bigger ideas to think about. ShipStation is the innovative tool that helps turn your shipping challenges into opportunities for growth. Go to shipstation.com and use code CASEFILE to sign up for your free 60 day trial. That's shipstation.com code CASEFILE. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre.
业务。而且，98% 使用 ShipStation 一年的公司成为了终身客户。让运输成为经营网店中最轻松的部分。你有更宏大的想法需要考虑。ShipStation 是一款创新的工具，可以帮助你将运输挑战转化为增长机遇。前往 shipstation.com 并使用代码 CASEFILE 注册，即可免费试用 60 天。网址是 shipstation.com，代码 CASEFILE。我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果你在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系你当地的危机中心。
For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. 18 year old Zeb Quinn started working part-time at the Hendersonville Road Walmart store in Asheville, North Carolina as a means to make money during high school. He enjoyed the job so much that he ended up staying on after graduation. Zeb had a learning disorder which had caused some difficulties in school and he'd always struggled to fit in. But at Walmart, his friendly nature, strong work ethic and dependability ensured he was well liked by his co-workers. Zeb had earned a reputation as a valued member of the electronics department team.
如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看你应用中或我们网站上本集的节目说明。18 岁的泽布·奎因（Zeb Quinn）开始在北卡罗来纳州阿什维尔的亨德森维尔路沃尔玛门店做兼职，以此作为高中期间赚取零花钱的一种方式。他非常喜欢这份工作，以至于毕业后留了下来。泽布患有学习障碍，这在学校里造成了一些困难，他一直难以融入集体。但在沃尔玛，他友好的天性、强烈的职业道德和可靠性确保了他深受同事们的喜爱。泽布在电子产品部门赢得了作为一名宝贵团队成员的声誉。
On days where he wasn't rusted on, he often stopped by the store just to drop breakfast off to his colleagues. Zeb's mum joked that he spent more time at Walmart than he did at home. In the two and a half years Zeb had been working there, he'd never once called in sick. Zeb's supervisor, Patty Andrick, was particularly fond of the 18-year-old. Despite their age difference, the two got along well. Every morning, Zeb called Patty at work just to chat and make sure he'd done everything Patty needed him to do. Patty was therefore puzzled when she received a phone call from Zeb's mother, Denise, on Monday January 3, 2000, asking if she knew where Zeb could be.
在不用上班的日子里，他经常顺道去店里给同事们送早餐。泽布的母亲开玩笑说，他在沃尔玛待的时间比在家里还多。在泽布在那里工作的两年半里，他从未请过病假。泽布的主管帕蒂·安德里克（Patty Andrick）特别喜欢这个 18 岁的年轻人。尽管年龄有差距，但两人相处得很好。每天早上，泽布都会在工作时给帕蒂打电话，只是为了聊天，并确保他已经完成了帕蒂需要他做的所有事情。因此，当帕蒂在 2000 年 1 月 3 日星期一接到泽布的母亲丹妮丝（Denise）打来的电话，询问她是否知道泽布在哪里时，她感到很困惑。
Denise said that her son hadn't returned home after his shift the previous night and she was getting worried. Patty hadn't seen or heard from Zeb since he clocked off around 9pm. She told Denise she'd contact her right away if she heard anything. The following day of Tuesday January 4, Zeb was rostered to work the afternoon shift at Walmart. His family hoped he'd show up safe and well, with a worthwhile explanation for his brief disappearance. At around 2pm, Patty Andrick was manning the electronics desk when the phone rang. Hi, this is Zeb, the caller said. I won't be in today. Patty knew Zeb's voice well. She didn't know who the caller was, but she was certain of one thing.
丹妮丝说，她的儿子前一天晚上轮班后没有回家，她开始担心起来。自泽布晚上 9 点左右下班后，帕蒂就再也没有见过他，也没有收到他的消息。她告诉丹妮丝，如果听到任何消息，她会立即联系她。第二天，即 1 月 4 日星期二，泽布被安排在沃尔玛上晚班。他的家人希望他能平安无事地出现，并对他短暂的失踪给出一个合理的解释。下午 2 点左右，帕蒂·安德里克正在电子产品柜台值班，电话响了。你好，我是泽布，打电话的人说。我今天不去上班了。帕蒂很熟悉泽布的声音。她不知道打电话的人是谁，但她确定一件事。
It wasn't Zeb, whom she affectionately described as a mummer's boy. After finishing high school, he willingly chose to remain living at home with his mother, just the two of them. Zeb's parents had divorced when he was a toddler and his older sister had recently gotten married and moved in with her husband. Zeb didn't have many close friends his own age to talk to, but he never hesitated to confide in his mother. So when Zeb failed to return home from work on the night of Sunday January 2, 2000, Denise sensed something was wrong.
那不是泽布，她亲切地称他为“妈妈的乖儿子”。高中毕业后，他自愿选择继续和母亲住在一起，家里只有他们两个人。泽布的父母在他蹒跚学步时就离婚了，他的姐姐最近刚结婚并搬去和丈夫一起住。泽布没有多少同龄的亲密朋友可以交谈，但他从不犹豫向母亲倾诉。因此，当泽布在 2000 年 1 月 2 日星期日晚上没有从工作岗位回家时，丹妮丝感觉到出了问题。
He usually came straight home, and if he didn't, he always contacted his mother to let her know where he was and what he was doing. Denise told herself that Zeb had probably just stopped off somewhere to play pool and you found hobby of his. His father, who owned a bar across town, had recently given him his own pool cue and Zeb was eager to use it. Zeb didn't have a mobile phone but he took his pager with him everywhere. A popular telecommunications device at the time, a call to a pager would leave a digital message for that person, typically in the form of a phone number. This would alert the user that someone was trying to reach them. Over the following hours,
他通常会直接回家，如果他不回家，他总是会联系母亲，让她知道他在哪里以及在做什么。丹妮丝告诉自己，泽布可能只是在某个地方停下来打台球，这是他新发现的爱好。他的父亲在城另一头拥有一家酒吧，最近给了他一根自己的台球杆，泽布很想用它。泽布没有手机，但他随身带着寻呼机。这是当时一种流行的电信设备，拨打寻呼机号码会给对方留下数字信息，通常是电话号码。这会提醒用户有人试图联系他们。在接下来的几个小时里，
Denise paged Zeb several times. He didn't respond. After a night of broken sleep, Denise spent all of Monday calling Zeb's friends and relatives. No one had heard from him or had any idea where he could be. When he still hadn't gotten in touch that evening, Denise called the police to report her son missing. As Zeb was 18 years old, he was free to come and go as he pleased. They reassured Denise he was likely just out, doing what teenage boys do, and would show up soon. When Zeb's work supervisor, Patty Andrick, received a call on Tuesday afternoon from an unfamiliar male claiming to be Zeb, she sprung into action. Patty began asking the caller work-related questions that only Zeb would know the answers to.
丹妮丝多次呼叫泽布。他没有回应。经过一个辗转反侧的夜晚，丹妮丝花了一整天时间给泽布的朋友和亲戚打电话。没有人收到他的消息，也不知道他可能在哪里。当那天晚上他仍然没有联系时，丹妮丝打电话给警察报告儿子失踪。由于泽布已经 18 岁，他可以自由出入。他们安慰丹妮丝说，他可能只是出去做十几岁男孩常做的事，很快就会出现。当泽布的工作主管帕蒂·安德里克在周二下午接到一个自称是泽布的陌生男子的电话时，她立即采取了行动。帕蒂开始问打电话的人只有泽布才知道答案的工作相关问题。
The caller stumbled to respond before abruptly ending the call. Patty immediately dialed star 69. In the United States, this call return feature automatically redials the last number that called through to a phone line. A woman answered, Volvo construction equipment, she said. How may I help you? Zeb Quinn had no connection to the Volvo plant, but one of his Walmart co-workers did. 22-year-old Robert Owens, who went by his middle name of Jason, worked part-time at both businesses. Colleagues had seen Zeb and Jason talking to one another just before Zeb clocked off on the night he disappeared. Zeb was in the market to buy a new car. Jason said he knew of one for sale that Zeb
打电话的人支支吾吾，随后突然挂断了电话。帕蒂立即拨打了 *69。在美国，这个回拨功能会自动重拨最后一个打入电话线的号码。一位女士接听了电话，沃尔沃建筑设备公司，她说。我能帮你什么吗？泽布·奎因与沃尔沃工厂没有任何联系，但他的一位沃尔玛同事有。22 岁的罗伯特·欧文斯（Robert Owens），大家都叫他中间名杰森（Jason），在这两家公司都做兼职。同事们看到泽布和杰森在泽布失踪当晚下班前正在交谈。泽布当时正打算买一辆新车。杰森说他知道有一辆车在卖，泽布
might be interested in. After learning about the call made to Patty Andrick, police officers went to speak to Jason Owens. He told them that after Zeb finished work on Sunday night, the pair met in the Walmart parking lot. The car Jason thought Zeb might like was a Mitsubishi Eclipse. It was parked out on Lester Highway, roughly 15 miles north. Jason had offered to drive out to show Zeb where it was. Zeb agreed. He got into his light blue Mazda Protege and tailed Jason's Ford pick-up truck. The two made a quick stop at a gas station on Hendersonville Road to grab a drink before hitting the road. According to Jason, a few minutes later Zeb started flashing his headlights. Taking this as a sign to pull over, Jason stopped on Longshul's Road, just around the corner from a
可能会感兴趣。在得知打给帕蒂·安德里克的电话后，警察去询问了杰森·欧文斯。他告诉他们，泽布周日晚上下班后，两人在沃尔玛停车场见了面。杰森认为泽布可能会喜欢的车是一辆三菱日蚀（Mitsubishi Eclipse）。它停在北边大约 15 英里外的莱斯特高速公路上。杰森主动提出开车带泽布去看车。泽布同意了。他坐进自己那辆浅蓝色的马自达 Protege，跟在杰森的福特皮卡车后面。两人在亨德森维尔路的一个加油站快速停了一下，买点饮料，然后继续上路。据杰森说，几分钟后，泽布开始闪烁前大灯。杰森认为这是靠边停车的信号，于是停在了离一所高中拐角处的朗肖尔斯路（Long Shoals Road）上。
high school. Zeb pulled up behind him and said he'd just received a page and had to make a call. He asked Jason if he had a cell phone he could use. Jason didn't. Zeb said he was going to find a payphone and would be back shortly. Jason told the police that he waited for 10 minutes before Zeb's Mazda reappeared. By this point, it was around 9.30pm. As Zeb pulled up behind Jason's truck, he bumped into the back of it. According to Jason, Zeb was frantic. In an obvious rush, he apologised and offered to pay for any damage but said he needed to cancel their plans. He'd just received another page and had to leave right away. With that, Jason watched as Zeb's Mazda disappeared from view. According to Jason, he had no idea that Zeb never returned home after that. Outside of work,
泽布停在他后面，说他刚收到一个寻呼，必须打个电话。他问杰森是否有手机可以借用。杰森没有。泽布说他要去寻找公用电话，很快就会回来。杰森告诉警察，他等了 10 分钟，泽布的马自达才重新出现。此时大约是晚上 9 点 30 分。当泽布停在杰森的卡车后面时，他撞到了卡车的后部。据杰森说，泽布当时很慌乱。他显然很匆忙，道歉并提出赔偿任何损失，但说他需要取消他们的计划。他刚收到另一个寻呼，必须立即离开。说完，杰森看着泽布的马自达消失在视线中。据杰森说，他根本不知道泽布在那之后就再也没有回家。在工作之外，
the pair occasionally played pool and went fishing together, but they weren't close friends. Jason said he therefore thought nothing of it when Zeb called him on Tuesday morning, asking if he'd do him a favour by calling in sick on his behalf. Police obtained the CCTV footage from the gas station on Hendersonville Road. At 9.14pm on Sunday January 2, the footage captured Jason Owens entering the store. Ten seconds later, Zeb Quinn entered behind him. The two young men purchased soft drinks before leaving via the same door. Two minutes later, both of their vehicles could be seen heading in the direction of Long Shoals Road, just like Jason Owens had described. For the police, Jason's story added weight to their belief that Zeb had likely left on
两人偶尔会一起打台球和钓鱼，但他们并不是亲密的朋友。因此，杰森说，当泽布在周二早上打电话给他，请求他帮忙代为请病假时，他并没有多想。警方获得了亨德森维尔路加油站的监控录像。1 月 2 日星期日晚上 9 点 14 分，录像捕捉到杰森·欧文斯进入商店。十秒钟后，泽布·奎因跟在他身后进入。两名年轻人买了软饮料，然后从同一扇门离开。两分钟后，可以看到他们的两辆车都朝着朗肖尔斯路的方向行驶，正如杰森·欧文斯所描述的那样。对于警方来说，杰森的说法增加了他们认为泽布很可能是
his own accord and would show up again soon. His mother Denise wanted to believe this too, but she wasn't so sure. Not only would it be completely out of character for Zeb to take off unannounced, he hadn't taken anything with him that indicated an intention to be gone for any amount of time. When he'd left Walmart, he was still dressed in his work uniform and didn't have a coat or any other change of clothes despite the January weather in North Carolina getting bitterly cold. Zeb also wore contact lenses but had left his contact solution at home. lenses but had left his contact solution at home. Denise knew there was no way Zeb would have run away for good or considered suicide. He was a happy young man who enjoyed his life and expressed excitement about the future.
自愿离开，很快就会再次出现的信念。他的母亲丹妮丝也想相信这一点，但她并不确定。泽布不仅不可能不辞而别，而且他没有带走任何表明他打算离开一段时间的东西。他离开沃尔玛时，仍然穿着工作制服，没有带外套或任何换洗衣服，尽管北卡罗来纳州一月份的天气变得非常寒冷。泽布还戴隐形眼镜，但他把护理液留在了家里。丹妮丝知道泽布绝不可能永远离家出走或考虑自杀。他是一个快乐的年轻人，享受着自己的生活，并对未来充满期待。
He'd recently purchased a new DVD player and satellite television system and was looking forward to setting them up. Zeb was also taking classes at the local community college and was looking forward to setting them up. Zeb was also taking classes at the local community college and was enrolled in the Reserve Officers Training Corps. While he loved his job at Walmart, his dream was to one day join the armed forces as a commissioned officer. Jason Owens told police that Zeb didn't mention who had been paging him so urgently. But those who knew Zeb well had their suspicions. Denise Quinn's boyfriend, Costa, ran a diner-style restaurant in Asheville called Costa's Kitchen. Zeb had a close relationship with Costa and often stopped by the restaurant to order his
他最近买了一台新的 DVD 播放机和卫星电视系统，并期待着安装它们。泽布还在当地社区学院上课，并报名参加了预备役军官训练团。虽然他热爱在沃尔玛的工作，但他的梦想是有朝一日能以军官的身份加入武装部队。杰森·欧文斯告诉警察，泽布没有提到是谁在如此紧急地呼叫他。但那些了解泽布的人有他们的怀疑。丹妮丝·奎因的男友科斯塔（Costa）在阿什维尔经营一家名为“科斯塔厨房”（Costa's Kitchen）的餐馆。泽布与科斯塔关系密切，经常顺道去餐馆点他
favourite menu item, the chicken tenders. In December 1999, just weeks before he disappeared, Zeb was at Kosta's kitchen when he struck up a conversation with a young woman named Misty Taylor. Misty's mother worked at the restaurant alongside Zeb's aunt. Misty and Zeb hit it off and became fast friends. But to those close to Zeb, it was obvious that his feelings went beyond just friendship. Zeb became infatuated with 19-year-old Misty, talking about her non-stop to anyone who would listen. The two began spending more and more time together, playing pool and hanging out at the mall. The problem was Misty was already in
最喜欢的菜单项目——鸡柳。1999 年 12 月，就在他失踪前几周，泽布在科斯塔厨房时与一位名叫米斯蒂·泰勒（Misty Taylor）的年轻女子交谈起来。米斯蒂的母亲在餐馆里和泽布的阿姨一起工作。米斯蒂和泽布一见如故，很快成了朋友。但对于那些与泽布亲近的人来说，很明显他的感情不仅仅是友谊。泽布迷恋上了 19 岁的米斯蒂，不停地向任何愿意听的人谈论她。两人开始花越来越多的时间在一起，打台球和在商场闲逛。问题是米斯蒂已经处于
a long-term relationship with a man named Wesley Smith. The two had a baby together. Zeb's family and friends urged him to cut ties with Misty, but Zeb didn't listen. Misty had apparently confided in him that Wesley had a jealous streak and was abusive towards her, and Zeb was determined to help her escape the relationship. By late December, some of Zeb's co-workers noted that he seemed nervous. Wesley had found out about the pair's newfound friendship and he wasn't happy. Word allegedly got out that Wesley and his friends warned Zeb to stay away. Zeb and Misty stayed in contact regardless, but Wesley soon found out about that
一段与名叫韦斯利·史密斯（Wesley Smith）的男子的长期关系中。两人还有一个孩子。泽布的家人和朋友劝他与米斯蒂断绝联系，但泽布没有听。米斯蒂显然向他吐露，韦斯利有嫉妒心，对她有虐待行为，泽布决心帮助她逃离这段关系。到 12 月下旬，泽布的一些同事注意到他看起来很紧张。韦斯利发现了两人新建立的友谊，他很不高兴。据称有传言说韦斯利和他的朋友警告泽布离她远点。无论如何，泽布和米斯蒂保持着联系，但韦斯利很快也发现了这一点。
too. According to one of Zeb's co-workers, on the day he went missing, he mentioned that someone had threatened his life. When Zeb had first failed to return home, Misty Taylor was one of the first people his mother called. Misty said she hadn't heard from Zeb and had no idea where he could be. According to Misty, on the night Zeb disappeared, she and her boyfriend Wesley had been having dinner at her mother's house, an alibi that checked out. For Zeb's loved ones, this raised the question. If Misty didn't send Zeb the urgent page, Then who did? As the days continued to pass with no word from Zeb, local newspapers started appealing for anyone with information to come forward.
据泽布的一位同事说，在他失踪的那天，他提到有人威胁了他的生命。当泽布第一次没有回家时，米斯蒂·泰勒是他母亲打给的第一批人之一。米斯蒂说她没有收到泽布的消息，也不知道他可能在哪里。据米斯蒂说，在泽布失踪的那天晚上，她和男友韦斯利在她母亲家吃晚饭，这个不在场证明得到了证实。对于泽布的亲人来说，这提出了一个问题：如果不是米斯蒂给泽布发了紧急寻呼，那会是谁呢？随着日子一天天过去，依然没有泽布的消息，当地报纸开始呼吁任何有信息的人站出来。
Citizens were urged to be on the lookout for the 18-year-old, who was described as 5 foot 10 and approximately 165 pounds with grey blue eyes and short brown hair. He was driving a light blue 1990 model Mazda Protege sedan. While police maintained that Zeb's disappearance wasn't being treated as suspicious, Denise Quinn grew more and more concerned. At the very least, her son was out there without a coat and she worried about how cold he could be. Denise told the Asheville Citizen Times, I just want to know my son is okay. It's just very weird. It's too weird. Adding to the strangeness of the case, police looked into Jason Owens and discovered that on the morning of Monday January 3, he called his supervisor at the Volvo plant to say he couldn't make it into work.
市民被敦促留意这名 18 岁的年轻人，他被描述为身高 5 英尺 10 英寸，体重约 165 磅，灰蓝色眼睛，短棕色头发。他驾驶着一辆浅蓝色的 1990 款马自达 Protege 轿车。虽然警方坚持认为泽布的失踪并未被视为可疑，但丹妮丝·奎因越来越担心。至少，她的儿子在外面没有外套，她担心他会冷成什么样。丹妮丝告诉《阿什维尔公民时报》：“我只想知道我儿子是否平安。这太奇怪了。太奇怪了。”为了增加案件的离奇程度，警方调查了杰森·欧文斯，发现 1 月 3 日星期一早上，他打电话给沃尔沃工厂的主管，说他不能去上班了。
He claimed he'd been in a car accident and was receiving treatment at the Urgent Care Centre on Hendersonville Road. Records confirmed that Jason Owens had checked himself into the centre at 9.40am, just over 12 hours after Zeb Quinn was last seen alive. He was treated for a head wound and fractured ribs, injuries that weren't consistent with Zeb Quinn rear-ending his car. When speaking to police, Jason claimed that this was a separate incident entirely. He said that several hours after his final encounter with Zab, he was driving past the Waffle House restaurant on Longshulves Road in the pre-dawn light when he collided with
他声称自己发生了车祸，正在亨德森维尔路的紧急护理中心接受治疗。记录证实，杰森·欧文斯于上午 9 点 40 分办理了入院手续，就在泽布·奎因最后一次被看到活着后的 12 小时多一点。他因头部受伤和肋骨骨折接受了治疗，这些伤势与泽布·奎因追尾他的车的情况不符。在接受警方询问时，杰森声称这是一起完全独立的事件。他说，在他与泽布最后一次相遇几个小时后，他在黎明前的光线下开车经过朗肖尔斯路上的华夫饼屋（Waffle House）餐馆时，与
another vehicle. Police checked their records. No accident reports had been filed for the early morning hours of Monday January 3 anywhere in the county. The injuries Jason Owens had been treated for also raised some questions as they weren't typical for a car accident. After giving his initial statement to the police, Jason Owens refused to cooperate any further. Although his behaviour raised suspicions, there was nothing to tie him to Zeb's disappearance. In fact, there was still nothing to confirm that Zeb had met with Fowl Play at all. His absence continued to be felt wholeheartedly by his loved ones.
另一辆车相撞了。警方检查了他们的记录。县内任何地方都没有 1 月 3 日星期一凌晨的事故报告。杰森·欧文斯接受治疗的伤势也引起了一些疑问，因为它们不是典型的车祸伤。在向警方提供初步陈述后，杰森·欧文斯拒绝进一步配合。尽管他的行为引起了怀疑，但没有任何证据将他与泽布的失踪联系起来。事实上，仍然没有任何证据证实泽布遭遇了不测。他的亲人依然深切地感受着他的缺席。
Denise Quinn couldn't ignore Zeb's favourite lounge chair which he typically kicked back on with his dog, Sam. The chair now sat empty, Sam's whimpers a constant reminder of the fact that Zeb was gone. Then, on January 16, 2000, exactly two weeks to the day since Zeb was last seen, Denise Quinn received a phone call. Denise worked at the Mission Hospital on McDow Street in downtown Asheville. A younger co-worker of hers had attended the same high school as Zeb and was following the news about his disappearance. She'd just passed by the Little Pig's BBQ restaurant which was adjacent to the hospital's parking lot and noticed a light blue Mazda parked there. She called Denise to let her know that it might be Zeb's. Denise rushed to the little pig's parking lot. Sure enough, it was Zeb's Mazda. Zeb himself was nowhere to be seen,
丹妮丝·奎因无法忽视泽布最喜欢的躺椅，他通常会带着他的狗萨姆（Sam）在那上面放松。椅子现在空着，萨姆的呜咽声不断提醒着人们泽布已经不在了。然后，在 2000 年 1 月 16 日，也就是泽布最后一次被看到整整两周后，丹妮丝·奎因接到了一个电话。丹妮丝在阿什维尔市中心的麦克道街（McDow Street）的使命医院（Mission Hospital）工作。她的一位年轻同事曾和泽布上同一所高中，并一直在关注关于他失踪的新闻。她刚经过医院停车场旁边的“小猪烧烤”（Little Pig's BBQ）餐馆，注意到那里停着一辆浅蓝色的马自达。她打电话给丹妮丝，告诉她那可能是泽布的车。丹妮丝冲向小猪烧烤的停车场。果然，那是泽布的马自达。泽布本人不见踪影，
but one look at the vehicle told Denise that something was wrong. The headlights were on and the windows were slightly ajar. On the rear windshield, someone had used what appeared to be pink lipstick to draw a large set of lips with an exclamation mark on either side. When police arrived, they opened the car doors to find something completely unexpected inside. A black Labrador cross puppy. The dog appeared to be approximately three months old and was completely unharmed, but nothing about her presence made sense. Zeb didn't own the puppy, nor had he mentioned wanting to get one. Also inside the car were several drink bottles, a plastic hotel keycard and a men's jacket, which Denise confirmed didn't belong to her son. None of these items held any obvious significance
但看了一眼车，丹妮丝就知道出事了。前大灯亮着，车窗微微打开。在后挡风玻璃上，有人用看起来像是粉红色口红的东西画了一组大嘴唇，两边各有一个感叹号。当警察到达时，他们打开车门，在里面发现了完全意想不到的东西。一只黑色拉布拉多混种小狗。这只狗看起来大约三个月大，完全没有受伤，但她出现在这里没有任何道理。泽布没有养这只小狗，也没有提到过想养一只。车内还有几个饮料瓶、一张塑料酒店房卡和一件男式夹克，丹妮丝证实这不属于她的儿子。这些物品中没有一件具有明显的意义
or indicated where Zeb could be. His family wondered whether he had intentionally left these clues behind to send some kind of message. Zeb's grandmother theorised that the drawing of the lips could be his way of sending kisses, and maybe he'd left the puppy there to signify that he was alive and well. One person even suggested that the puppy was a sign of guilt from whoever had dumped the car. Perhaps they felt so bad about what happened to Zeb that they left the dog to console his family. Others thought the puppy had been planted there to ensure the car didn't go unnoticed. If the abandoned vehicle hadn't sparked attention, a yapping puppy surely would. The location also raised some questions. Zeb's sister Brandy also worked at the Mission Hospital.
或表明泽布可能在哪里。他的家人想知道他是否故意留下这些线索来传达某种信息。泽布的祖母推测，画嘴唇可能是他发送吻的方式，也许他把小狗留在那里是为了表示他还活着并且很好。甚至有人建议，这只小狗是任何丢弃这辆车的人感到内疚的标志。也许他们对泽布的遭遇感到非常难过，以至于他们留下这只狗来安慰他的家人。其他人认为小狗被放在那里是为了确保车不会被忽视。如果被遗弃的车辆没有引起注意，一只叫唤的小狗肯定会。这个地点也引起了一些疑问。泽布的姐姐布兰迪（Brandy）也在使命医院工作。
The two siblings were incredibly close. Zeb often called Brandy at the home she shared with her husband and young daughter just to tell her that he loved her. Some wondered if Zeb had intentionally left the car at the Little Pig's restaurant because there was a higher chance that his family would find it. But Denise Quinn didn't think so. Zeb knew that his mother and sister typically used the entrance at the other side of the hospital. If he wanted them to find his car, Denise felt there were better places he could have left it. find his car, Denise felt there were better places he could have left it. When police examined the vehicle, they realised that the driver's seat had been pulled close to the steering wheel. Zeb was 5 foot 10 and he typically kept the seat pushed further back.
这对姐弟关系非常亲密。泽布经常给布兰迪打电话，打给她和丈夫及年幼女儿住的地方，只是为了告诉她他爱她。有些人想知道泽布是否故意把车留在小猪烧烤餐馆，因为他的家人更有可能在那里找到它。但丹妮丝·奎因不这么认为。泽布知道他的母亲和姐姐通常使用医院另一侧的入口。如果他想让他们找到他的车，丹妮丝觉得有更好的地方可以留下它。当警察检查车辆时，他们意识到驾驶座被拉到了靠近方向盘的位置。泽布身高 5 英尺 10 英寸，他通常把座位推得更靠后。
With the seat positioned the way it was, there was no way he could have comfortably driven the car. the way it was, there was no way he could have comfortably driven the car. Whoever it was that had driven the vehicle to the parking lot, it wasn't Zeb Quinn. The discovery of Zeb's Mazda was a major breakthrough, but the clues left inside only raised more questions. The hotel keycard was just a blank white card with no information on it. It didn't include the hotel's name, a logo or guest room number. Police made inquiries with various accommodation providers but couldn't determine where the keycard originated from. No one could figure out where the puppy had come from either. Police couldn't even be sure what had been used to draw the lips and exclamation marks on the rear windshield.
以这种方式放置座位，他根本不可能舒适地驾驶这辆车。无论是谁把车开到停车场，那都不是泽布·奎因。泽布马自达的发现是一个重大突破，但留在里面的线索只会引发更多问题。酒店房卡只是一张空白的白卡，上面没有任何信息。它不包括酒店名称、标志或客房号码。警方向各住宿提供商进行了查询，但无法确定房卡的来源。也没有人能弄清楚小狗是从哪里来的。警方甚至无法确定后挡风玻璃上的嘴唇和感叹号是用什么画的。
It appeared to be lipstick, but one detective told ABC 13 News that it could have also been paint, crayon or magic marker. Staff at the Little Pig's restaurant recalled that the Mazda hadn't been parked there the evening before it was found. This, along with the wellbeing of the puppy, meant it had only been abandoned hours before it was discovered. There wasn't a single piece of evidence to indicate foul play, nor was there anything to suggest that Zeb had voluntarily run away. The Asheville police captain told reporters that they couldn't decide whether the car turning up was a good or bad sign. Speaking to the Asheville Citizen Times, he commented, he commented, "...it's hard to say what this indicates. If anybody saw that car anywhere, they should let me know." The next day, a couple came forward to report that a few days prior to
看起来像是口红，但一位侦探告诉 ABC 13 新闻，它也可能是油漆、蜡笔或记号笔。小猪烧烤餐馆的工作人员回忆说，马自达在前一天晚上并没有停在那里。这，连同小狗的健康状况，意味着它是在被发现前几个小时才被遗弃的。没有任何证据表明发生了不测，也没有任何迹象表明泽布是自愿离家出走的。阿什维尔警察局长告诉记者，他们无法决定这辆车的出现是好兆头还是坏兆头。在接受《阿什维尔公民时报》采访时，他评论道：“……很难说这说明了什么。如果有人在任何地方看到那辆车，他们应该告诉我。”第二天，一对夫妇站出来报告说，在
the car being found, they'd seen a woman driving it around downtown Asheville. The woman appeared to be around 25 to 30 years old with wavy, light brown hair. The couple agreed to help put together a composite sketch of the driver. When police saw it, they couldn't deny the similarities it bore to Misty Taylor. Misty was questioned, but she denied having driven Zeb's car and maintained that she had no idea where he was or what happened to him. With a solid alibi and no concrete evidence to suggest she knew otherwise, police hit a dead end. Zeb's family hired a private detective, but he too remained baffled by the presence of Zeb's vehicle, telling Spin magazine, "...it goes against all reason of criminality for the car to be here. It's just common sense. You
车被发现的前几天，他们看到一个女人在阿什维尔市中心开着它。那个女人看起来大约 25 到 30 岁，留着波浪状的浅棕色头发。这对夫妇同意协助制作驾驶员的合成素描。当警察看到它时，他们无法否认它与米斯蒂·泰勒的相似之处。米斯蒂受到了质询，但她否认开过泽布的车，并坚持说她不知道他在哪里，也不知道发生了什么事。由于有可靠的不在场证明，且没有确凿证据表明她知道内情，警方陷入了死胡同。泽布的家人聘请了一名私家侦探，但他也被泽布车辆的出现弄糊涂了，他告诉《Spin》杂志：“……车出现在这里违背了所有犯罪逻辑。这只是常识。你
don't just go riding around in a car led to an increase in media attention, and tips continued to come in. Police explored each one, but nothing substantial emerged. Zeb's co-workers at Walmart rallied behind the Quinn family by pinning yellow ribbons to their work uniforms, a symbol of hope for Zeb's safe return. A poster with the Zeb's picture detailing his last known movements was displayed at the front of the store, urging customers to come forward if they had any information that could help with the investigation. Walmart staff even opened a fundraising account to help Denise pay for her independent search efforts and encouraged customers to donate to the fund. Zeb's father, Jerry Quinn, refused to give up hope that his son was still alive. The two hadn't spent much time together
不会只是开着一辆车到处转悠。”这导致媒体关注度增加，线索不断涌入。警方探索了每一条线索，但没有实质性进展。沃尔玛的泽布同事们通过在工作制服上别上黄丝带支持奎因一家，这是泽布平安归来的希望象征。一张带有泽布照片并详细说明他最后已知行踪的海报被张贴在商店前，敦促顾客如果他们有任何可以帮助调查的信息，请站出来。沃尔玛员工甚至开设了一个筹款账户，帮助丹妮丝支付她独立搜寻工作的费用，并鼓励顾客向该基金捐款。泽布的父亲杰里·奎因（Jerry Quinn）拒绝放弃他儿子还活着的希望。两人在泽布的童年时期
during Zeb's childhood, but they'd recently rekindled their relationship. during Zeb's childhood, but they'd recently rekindled their relationship. Jerry was certain Zeb would contact him on his birthday. Jerry spent the entire day by the phone, but the date passed with no word from Zeb. The longer Zeb remained missing, the more the rumour mill swung into overdrive. Locals began considering all kinds of outlandish theories, none of which held any merit. The private investigator hired by the Quinn family told journalist Brett Forrest for Spin Magazine, "...I have checked everything I can possibly think of. Gangs, witchcraft, drugs, deviant sexual behaviour. And I can't come up with an explanation for the lips on the back of the car." It took a while before police were able to
并没有花太多时间在一起，但他们最近重燃了父子关系。杰里确信泽布会在他生日那天联系他。杰里整天守在电话旁，但日期过去了，没有泽布的消息。泽布失踪的时间越长，谣言就越疯狂。当地人开始考虑各种离奇的理论，没有一个是有根据的。奎因一家聘请的私家侦探告诉《Spin》杂志的记者布雷特·福雷斯特（Brett Forrest）：“……我已经检查了我能想到的所有事情。帮派、巫术、毒品、变态性行为。我无法对车后的嘴唇做出解释。”警方花了很长时间才能够
access the records for Zeb's pager. Looking through the data from the night he disappeared, it seemed that Jason Owens had been telling the truth. Zeb had indeed received a page just a few minutes after the two of them left the gas station. The number was traced to the apartment of Ina Rustich, Zeb's paternal aunt. Police went to speak with Ina. She vehemently denied having ever paged to Zeb and said she wasn't even home on the night in question. She'd been eating dinner at her friend, Tamra Taylor's house. The two women worked together at Kosta's Kitchen, the restaurant owned by Denise Quinn's boyfriend. Coincidentally, the police already knew about this dinner.
访问泽布寻呼机的记录。查看他失踪当晚的数据，似乎杰森·欧文斯说的是实话。泽布确实在他们两人离开加油站几分钟后收到了一个寻呼。该号码被追踪到泽布的父系阿姨伊娜·鲁斯蒂奇（Ina Rustich）的公寓。警察去和伊娜谈话。她强烈否认曾经呼叫过泽布，并说她在事发当晚甚至不在家。她一直在她朋友塔玛拉·泰勒（Tamra Taylor）家吃晚饭。这两名妇女在科斯塔厨房一起工作，那是丹妮丝·奎因男友拥有的餐馆。巧合的是，警方已经知道了这顿晚餐。
Tamara Taylor was Misty Taylor's mother. It was this dinner that both Misty and her boyfriend Wesley Smith had attended on the night Zeb went missing, thus giving them both airtight alibis. The problem was, Ina Rustich lived alone and she said no one else had a key to her apartment. So how could Zeb have received a page from her phone? According to Ina, when she returned home after Tamara's dinner, it seemed that someone had broken into her apartment. Nothing appeared to be missing, but various items were out of place and the phone had been moved to a different part of the house.
塔玛拉·泰勒是米斯蒂·泰勒的母亲。正是这顿晚餐，米斯蒂和她的男友韦斯利·史密斯在泽布失踪当晚都参加了，从而给了他们两人无懈可击的不在场证明。问题是，伊娜·鲁斯蒂奇独自居住，她说没有其他人有她公寓的钥匙。那么泽布怎么可能收到来自她电话的寻呼呢？据伊娜说，当她在塔玛拉的晚餐后回到家时，似乎有人闯入了她的公寓。没有任何东西丢失，但各种物品位置不对，电话被移到了房子的不同地方。
Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. Police checked Ina Ustich's phone records and discovered that three minutes after Zeb Quinn received the page from Ina's number, someone called her apartment. The number was traced to the home of Ina's brother, Jerry Quinn, Zeb's father. But Jerry strongly denied making the call to Ina's apartment on the night that Zeb disappeared. Like Ina, he claimed he wasn't even home at the time. Jerry owned a bar in Asheville's Biltmore Village area and he'd been working on the night in question. He told the Asheville Citizen Times,
Casefile 稍后回来。感谢你通过收听本集的赞助商来支持我们。感谢你收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，你支持 Casefile 继续提供高质量的内容。警方检查了伊娜·鲁斯蒂奇的电话记录，发现泽布·奎因收到来自伊娜号码的寻呼三分钟后，有人给她的公寓打了电话。该号码被追踪到伊娜的兄弟杰里·奎因（泽布的父亲）的家中。但杰里强烈否认在泽布失踪当晚给伊娜的公寓打过电话。像伊娜一样，他声称他当时甚至不在家。杰里在阿什维尔的比尔特莫尔村（Biltmore Village）地区拥有一家酒吧，他在事发当晚一直在工作。他告诉《阿什维尔公民时报》，
I didn't make no call. I don't know who could have done that. Police considered whether Zeb could have made the call to Wynna's house from his father's apartment. But Jerry lived roughly seven miles north from the location on Longsholz Road where Jason Owens claimed Zeb left him to return the urgent page. The call to Ina's apartment was placed just three minutes after Zeb received the page. That wouldn't have given him enough time to drive to Jerry's place and make the call. It also wouldn't make sense for him to do so given there were plenty of payphones in the area. Ina Ustich's phone records also revealed that in the days following Zeb's disappearance, several other calls had been made from her apartment at times when she wasn't at home.
“我没打过电话。我不知道是谁干的。”警方考虑泽布是否可能从他父亲的公寓给伊娜家打了电话。但杰里住在距离杰森·欧文斯声称泽布离开他去回那个紧急寻呼的朗肖尔斯路地点大约七英里北边的地方。打给伊娜公寓的电话是在泽布收到寻呼三分钟后拨出的。这没有给他足够的时间开车去杰里家并拨打电话。考虑到该地区有大量的公用电话，他这样做也没有意义。伊娜·鲁斯蒂奇的电话记录还显示，在泽布失踪后的几天里，她的公寓在不在家的时候还拨出了其他几个电话。
On one of those days, she claimed she returned home to find a picture had fallen off the wall and broken. Ina was subject to a polygraph test, which she passed. Outside of the unexplained page to Zeb, there was nothing to connect her with the case. Regardless, some continued to suspect she knew more about Zeb's whereabouts than she was letting on. Unfounded rumours swelled that she could have been helping to hide her nephew. Jerry Quinn told Spin Magazine that he'd threatened his sister, warning, If I find you're hiding something, I swear to God I will cripple you for life. Every time you get up and hobble, you'll think about me. You're my family, but here's my baby." Ina was distraught by this and swore she didn't know anything. Nevertheless, Jerry told Spin, something makes me feel pretty weird about her.
在其中一天，她声称她回到家发现一张照片从墙上掉下来摔碎了。伊娜接受了测谎仪测试，她通过了。除了那个无法解释的给泽布的寻呼外，没有任何东西将她与此案联系起来。无论如何，一些人继续怀疑她知道的比她透露的关于泽布下落的事情更多。毫无根据的谣言甚嚣尘上，说她可能一直在帮助隐藏她的侄子。杰里·奎因告诉《Spin》杂志，他曾威胁过他的妹妹，警告说：“如果我发现你在隐瞒什么，我发誓我会让你终身残废。每次你站起来一瘸一拐地走，你都会想到我。你是我的家人，但那是我的孩子。”伊娜对此感到心烦意乱，并发誓她什么都不知道。尽管如此，杰里告诉《Spin》，“有些事情让我觉得她很奇怪。”
makes me feel pretty weird about her. Unable to handle the scrutiny, Ina moved into state. She told the Asheville Citizen Times she had no idea what happened to Zeb, stating, I could never do anything to harm a hair on that boy's head. I love him. I'm just like everyone else. I want to know what happened." By the time Zeb Quinn had been missing for seven months, police had followed up on approximately 150 leads. They'd even taken seriously two separate reports from local women who claimed to have psychic visions in which Zeb was dead and buried. One of the women claimed that the murder weapon had been thrown into Lake Julian near Long Shoals Road and took police out on a fruitless search for it. Denise Quinn continued to do all
无法承受这种审查，伊娜搬到了州外。她告诉《阿什维尔公民时报》，她不知道泽布发生了什么事，并表示：“我绝不会做任何伤害那个孩子一根头发的事。我爱他。我和其他人一样。我想知道发生了什么。”到泽布·奎因失踪七个月时，警方已经跟进了大约 150 条线索。他们甚至认真对待了当地两名妇女的单独报告，她们声称有通灵幻象，泽布已经死亡并被埋葬。其中一名妇女声称凶器被扔进了朗肖尔斯路附近的朱利安湖（Lake Julian），并带着警察进行了一次毫无结果的搜寻。丹妮丝·奎因继续做所有
she could to find her son, handing out missing person flyers, speaking to reporters and searching for his face among crowds. Locals were reminded of Denise's heartache every time they drove by a billboard in town she'd paid for, which read, "'Zab, lots of people love you and miss you. Honey, where are you? I miss you so much. Love, Mum." With no confirmed sightings and Zeb's bank account and social security number remaining untouched, investigators came to the conclusion that Zeb had most likely been the victim of a homicide. If so, they believed that the killer didn't act alone. One police spokesperson said, "...just the mechanics of killing someone and disposing of the body would lead us to believe more than one person had to be involved." While they remained open to the possibility
她能做的事来寻找她的儿子，分发失踪人员传单，与记者交谈，并在人群中寻找他的脸。每当当地人开车经过她付费购买的广告牌时，都会想起丹妮丝的心碎，上面写着：“泽布，很多人爱你并想念你。亲爱的，你在哪里？我太想你了。爱你的妈妈。”由于没有确定的目击记录，且泽布的银行账户和社会安全号码保持不动，调查人员得出结论，泽布很可能是凶杀案的受害者。如果是这样，他们认为凶手不是一个人行动。一位警方发言人说：“……仅仅是杀人并处理尸体的过程就让我们相信，必须有不止一个人参与其中。”虽然他们仍然对
that Zeb could still be alive, they uncovered no reason to suggest that he left voluntarily. The Quinn family considered whether Zeb could have gotten into a scuffle with someone that had gotten out of hand. He could be naive and it was possible that he was placed in a difficult situation that he didn't know how to get out of. Denise Quinn told the Asheville Citizen Times, I'm angry at the people here who know something but who won't say anything. I just need to know whether he's dead or alive. I just need to know whether I should grieve or wish him well. If someone would just drop us an anonymous note or tell us where he's buried, I just
泽布可能还活着持开放态度，但他们没有发现任何迹象表明他是自愿离开的。奎因一家考虑泽布是否可能与某人发生了失控的争执。他可能很天真，有可能他陷入了一个他不知道如何摆脱的困境。丹妮丝·奎因告诉《阿什维尔公民时报》：“我对这里知道一些事情但不愿说出来的人感到愤怒。我只需要知道他是死是活。我只需要知道我应该哀悼还是祝他安好。如果有人能给我们留一张匿名纸条，或者告诉我们他被埋在哪里，我只
want to be able to find some peace." One detective told the Hickory Daily Record, "...it's very frustrating. You feel for the parents and wish you could give them an answer. Sometimes you get a case that there just aren't any answers to." aren't any answers to. The one year anniversary of Zeb's disappearance came and went with the $15,000 reward for information going unclaimed. Zeb had missed Christmas, his favourite holiday, and the birth of his second niece, further adding to the belief that he was no longer alive. Denise Quinn had since gotten engaged to her boyfriend, Costa, and it broke her heart that Zab wouldn't be there to walk her down the aisle.
想能够找到一些平静。”一位侦探告诉《希科里每日记录》：“……这非常令人沮丧。你为父母感到难过，希望你能给他们一个答案。有时你会遇到一个根本没有任何答案的案件。”泽布失踪一周年纪念日过去了，15,000 美元的悬赏金无人认领。泽布错过了他最喜欢的节日圣诞节，以及他第二个侄女的出生，这进一步增加了他已经不在人世的信念。丹妮丝·奎因后来与她的男友科斯塔订婚了，泽布不能在那里陪她走过红毯让她心碎。
Denise had no doubt that someone in town knew something they refused to disclose. She told the Asheville Citizen Times, "...somebody had his car and if nothing else they know where they got it. Even if they found it abandoned, they know where it was and it could be the one thing that would help. Zeb's father Jerry blamed police incompetence for the lack of progress in his son's case. The Asheville Police Department was only small and officers lacked the experience and resources required for a case of this magnitude. Jerry was convinced that Misty Taylor's boyfriend, Wesley Smith, had something to do with Zeb's disappearance. While local suspicion remained against Misty and Wesley, many believed there was a more obvious culprit.
丹妮丝毫不怀疑城里有人知道一些他们拒绝透露的事情。她告诉《阿什维尔公民时报》：“……有人有他的车，如果什么都不知道，他们至少知道他们是从哪里得到的。即使他们发现它是被遗弃的，他们也知道它在哪里，这可能是唯一能提供帮助的事情。”泽布的父亲杰里将案件缺乏进展归咎于警方无能。阿什维尔警察局规模很小，警官缺乏处理这种规模案件所需的经验和资源。杰里确信米斯蒂·泰勒的男友韦斯利·史密斯与泽布的失踪有关。虽然当地对米斯蒂和韦斯利的怀疑依然存在，但许多人认为有一个更明显的罪魁祸首。
Jason Owens. Not only was he the last person seen with Zeb, the fact that he'd called Walmart pretending to be Zeb was a detail many couldn't get past. Jason continued to not cooperate with the police and spoke publicly about the case only once telling Spin Magazine, I was totally in the wrong place at the wrong time. If just one thing different would have happened, I wouldn't be in the middle of it. But I'm in the middle of it. Stuck here until something's figured out. Locals weren't the only ones suspicious of Jason Owens.
杰森·欧文斯。他不仅是最后见到泽布的人，而且他曾冒充泽布给沃尔玛打电话，这一细节让许多人无法释怀。杰森继续不配合警方调查，且仅有一次公开谈论此案，他对《Spin》杂志说：“我完全是在错误的时间出现在了错误的地点。如果当时哪怕有一件事发生了改变，我就不会卷入其中。但我确实卷入其中了，在事情查清之前，我只能困在这里。”当地人并非唯一怀疑杰森·欧文斯的人。
Police also couldn't shake the feeling that he was involved in Zeb's disappearance in some way. During the course of their investigation, intriguing information had emerged. As detailed in the documentary A Good Kid, police records revealed that on the morning Zeb went missing, Jason Owen's mother had called the County Sheriff's Department. The call placed at 7am was to report that her own son was missing. She'd become worried that Jason had failed to return home after going out the night before. With all this information combined, police felt they had enough evidence to establish probable cause. In February 2001, 13 months after Zeb's disappearance, a judge issued a warrant for officers to draw hair, blood and saliva samples from Jason Owens.
警方也无法摆脱他以某种方式参与了泽布失踪案的感觉。在调查过程中，一些耐人寻味的信息浮出水面。正如纪录片《好孩子》中所详述的那样，警方记录显示，在泽布失踪的那天早上，杰森·欧文斯的母亲曾致电县治安官办公室。这通在早上7点打出的电话是为了报告她自己的儿子失踪了。她担心杰森前一天晚上出去后没有回家。综合所有这些信息，警方认为他们有足够的证据来确立合理怀疑。2001年2月，即泽布失踪13个月后，法官签发了搜查令，允许警官提取杰森·欧文斯的毛发、血液和唾液样本。
While they didn't necessarily have any samples to compare them against, at least they now had them on file. But by late October 2002, almost three years had passed. There hadn't been a single breakthrough in the Zeb Quinn case. hadn't been a single breakthrough in the Zeb Quinn case. In the early hours of Tuesday October 29, Asheville Police Officer Diana Loveland was driving along Interstate 240 on her way back to the station when she saw a pickup truck hurdling down the highway. Suspecting the driver was intoxicated, Officer Loveland flashed her lights and signalled for them to pull over. Instead, the driver picked up speed. With Officer Loveland giving chase and calling for
虽然他们不一定有任何样本可以进行比对，但至少现在已经存档了。然而到了2002年10月下旬，近三年时间过去了，泽布·奎因案仍未取得任何突破。2002年10月29日星期二凌晨，阿什维尔警官戴安娜·洛夫兰在返回警局的途中沿着240号州际公路行驶时，看到一辆皮卡车在高速公路上疾驰。怀疑司机酒驾，洛夫兰警官闪烁警灯并示意对方靠边停车。然而，司机反而加速了。在洛夫兰警官追赶并呼叫
backup, the pickup truck eventually exited onto Long Shoals Road. Maintaining speeds of over 80 miles per hour, the driver suddenly raised a gun and began shooting out the window. Then after speeding through an intersection, the vehicle hit a mailbox and flipped. The driver was none other than 24-year-old Jason Owens. Jason was treated in hospital for several days before being arrested on nine charges related to the high-speed chase, including a looting arrest and assault on a law enforcement officer with a firearm. He ultimately pleaded guilty and was sentenced to eight months in prison.
支援时，皮卡车最终驶向了朗肖尔斯路。在保持时速超过80英里的情况下，司机突然举起一把枪，开始向窗外射击。随后，车辆在穿过一个十字路口后撞上了一个邮箱并翻车。司机正是24岁的杰森·欧文斯。杰森在医院接受了几天治疗，随后因与这场高速追逐相关的九项指控被捕，其中包括抢劫罪和持枪袭击执法人员罪。他最终认罪，被判处八个月监禁。
Police refused to say whether Jason Owens was questioned further about Zeb Quinn as part of the car chase investigation, but a healthcare professional recommended he seek treatment for alcohol abuse. Two months later, in December 2002, cadets from the Reserve Officers Training Corps unit that Zeb had been part of surprised his family with a memorial service in Zeb's honour. With the three-year anniversary of his disappearance approaching, they wanted Zeb's loved ones to know that his case hadn't been forgotten. Denise held back tears as she was presented with a photo of her son in a memory book the cadets had put together. The ambiguous loss no easier to live with despite the years that had passed. As time wore on, officers spoke to criminal profilers,
警方拒绝透露杰森·欧文斯是否在车祸追逐调查中就泽布·奎因案接受了进一步审讯，但一位医疗专业人士建议他接受酒精滥用治疗。两个月后的2002年12月，泽布曾参加过的预备役军官训练团的学员们为他的家人举办了一场纪念仪式，给了他们一个惊喜。随着他失踪三周年的临近，他们希望泽布的亲人们知道，他的案子并没有被遗忘。当学员们制作的纪念册中展示她儿子的照片时，丹妮丝强忍着泪水。尽管多年过去，这种模糊的丧亲之痛依然难以承受。随着时间的推移，警官们与犯罪侧写师进行了交谈，
searched various areas with cadaver dogs, and followed up on all reported sightings to no impact. sightings to no impact. 2007 marked the seventh year of the investigation. That year, in April, new evidence emerged that allowed police to get a search warrant for Jason Owen's property. He lived with his wife on Owens Cove Road, a remote dead-end stretch in Leicester, roughly 14 miles from downtown Asheville. Over the years, Jason continued to rack up criminal convictions, receiving charges for distributing prescription drugs and being in possession of stolen goods. Police wouldn't tell the media what the new evidence was, simply commenting, we hope we can further the investigation. We are leaving no stone unturned."
用搜尸犬搜查了各个区域，并跟进了所有报告的目击线索，但都毫无结果。2007年是调查的第七个年头。那年4月，新的证据出现，使警方得以获得搜查杰森·欧文斯房产的搜查令。他和妻子住在莱斯特市欧文斯湾路上一条偏远的死胡同里，距离阿什维尔市中心约14英里。多年来，杰森不断累积犯罪记录，因分发处方药和持有赃物而受到指控。警方没有向媒体透露新证据是什么，只是评论道：“我们希望能够推进调查。我们不会放过任何蛛丝马迹。”
Officers also sought help from NecroSearch, a non-profit organisation dedicated to helping law enforcement uncover clandestine graves and other evidence. They used aerial photography and ground-penetrating radar to search Jason's expansive wooded property. Nothing of interest was found. In the two years that followed, police started re-investigating Zeb's disappearance from scratch. They obtained DNA from Misty Taylor and Wesley Smith, who had collectively been questioned nine times since January 2000. Police made it clear that neither Misty nor Wesley were being treated as suspects, and that collection of their DNA was simply part of their comprehensive efforts.
警官们还寻求了NecroSearch的帮助，这是一个致力于协助执法部门发现秘密墓地和其他证据的非营利组织。他们利用航空摄影和探地雷达搜查了杰森广阔的林地房产。但没有发现任何有价值的东西。在随后的两年里，警方开始从头重新调查泽布的失踪案。他们获得了米斯蒂·泰勒和韦斯利·史密斯的DNA，自2000年1月以来，他们总共被审问了九次。警方明确表示，米斯蒂和韦斯利都没有被视为嫌疑人，采集他们的DNA只是全面调查工作的一部分。
No new discoveries emerged, and by the 10-year anniversary of Zeb's disappearance in 2010, his case remained one of 23 on the Asheville Police Department's cold case list. Officers once again appealed for information in the hopes that loyalties might have changed over time. A tearful Denise Quinn told the Asheville Citizen Times, Quinn told the Ashville Citizen Times, basically all of us are, to a point, stuck on that day when Zeb disappeared. With no sense of what happened to him or where his remains were, Denise said, just not having anything is torture. It doesn't go away. She wrote an open letter to the people of Asheville saying, for now, until someone realises it has been way too long and calls in some information to help us,
没有新的发现，到2010年泽布失踪10周年时，他的案子仍然是阿什维尔警察局悬案名单上的23起案件之一。警官们再次呼吁提供信息，希望人们的忠诚度可能随着时间的推移而改变。泪流满面的丹妮丝·奎因告诉《阿什维尔公民时报》：“基本上，我们所有人都被困在了泽布失踪的那一天。”由于不知道他发生了什么，也不知道他的遗体在哪里，丹妮丝说：“什么都不知道简直是一种折磨。这种感觉挥之不去。”她写了一封公开信给阿什维尔的人民，说道：“现在，直到有人意识到时间已经过去太久，并打来电话提供一些信息来帮助我们，
all we can do is wait, day by day, to hear that the police have finally gotten the break they need to answer our prayers. By the start of 2015, 15 years had passed with no answers for Zeb's loved ones, despite the case receiving national coverage when it was featured on an episode of Investigation Discovery's Disappeared program. Zeb's disappearance had become somewhat of an urban legend. It continued to be talked about from time to time, and locals held onto their theories, but it had mostly faded from the public consciousness. Police Sergeant Chuck Sams was one of few reminded of the case every day. He'd been on duty on the day Zeb's car was found. Chuck adopted the puppy found inside, giving her the name Katie. Katie had gone on to live a long and happy life,
我们所能做的就是日复一日地等待，等待听到警方终于取得了他们需要的突破，以回应我们的祈祷。”到2015年初，15年过去了，泽布的亲人们仍然没有得到答案，尽管该案在调查发现频道的《失踪》节目中播出后获得了全国性的报道。泽布的失踪已经成为某种都市传说。人们不时谈论它，当地人也坚持自己的理论，但它在公众意识中已经逐渐淡去。警长查克·萨姆斯是少数每天都被提醒想起这个案子的人之一。泽布的车被发现那天他正在值班。查克收养了车里发现的那只小狗，给她取名凯蒂。凯蒂后来过上了长久而幸福的生活，
but she was a living reminder of the ongoing mystery. For engaged couple Christy Schoen and JT Codd, the mountainous area surrounding Asheville, North Carolina seemed like the perfect place to settle down. Having both spent many years working long hours in the entertainment industry, they were excited to slow down and start a family. The two had met behind the scenes on a television show. JT, whose real name was Joseph, worked as a key grip responsible for all non-electrical support gear on set. Christy worked as a professional caterer, leaning into skills she'd developed having grown up in Louisiana cooking Cajun cuisine with her father. She was also an aspiring actor who did occasional work
但她是一个活生生的提醒，提醒着这起悬而未决的谜案。对于订婚的情侣克里斯蒂·肖恩和JT·科德来说，北卡罗来纳州阿什维尔周围的山区似乎是安家的完美之地。两人都在娱乐行业工作多年，工作时间很长，他们很高兴能放慢脚步，组建家庭。两人是在一部电视剧的幕后相识的。JT（真名约瑟夫）是一名关键场务，负责片场所有非电气支撑设备。克里斯蒂是一名专业餐饮服务商，她利用了自己从小在路易斯安那州随父亲烹饪卡津美食所培养的技能。她还是一位有抱负的演员，偶尔从事
as a stunt double. In 2012, Christie combined these two passions by appearing as a contestant on the reality television show Food Network Star. Although she was eliminated in the first round, her passion for food only grew stronger. When Christie and JT decided to leave Los Angeles for North Carolina and purchase a 36-acre property on Hookers Gap Road in Leicester, they had a shared vision. They'd used the property to grow their own food, which they'd then used to start a farm-to-table café. With a variety of established fruit trees on the land already, the property suited them well. A close friend of JT's told People magazine that while the property wasn't exactly remarkable, quote, JT was making it remarkable, because that's what he did with everything.
特技替身工作。2012年，克里斯蒂通过参加真人秀节目《美食网明星》将这两个爱好结合起来。虽然她在第一轮就被淘汰了，但她对食物的热情却愈发高涨。当克里斯蒂和JT决定离开洛杉矶前往北卡罗来纳州，并在莱斯特的胡克斯峡谷路购买了一处36英亩的房产时，他们有着共同的愿景。他们利用这处房产种植自己的食物，然后用这些食物开一家从农场到餐桌的咖啡馆。由于土地上已经有各种成熟的果树，这处房产非常适合他们。JT的一位密友告诉《人物》杂志，虽然这处房产并不算特别出众，但“JT正在让它变得出众，因为他对待每件事都是这样。”
JT and Christy quickly found their place in their new community and got married at a community centre outside of Asheville. A few months later, they shared the news with their loved ones that Christy was pregnant. When they found out they were having a girl, they decided on the name Skylar. For the newlyweds, everything was falling into place. Then on Sunday March 15 2015, one of their neighbours, Cecilia Owens, received a phone call. It was Christie's father calling from his home in Mississippi. He'd become concerned after Christy, who was five months pregnant, had failed to show up for a planned visit without any explanation. He hadn't been able to get in touch with her since. Cecilia Owens had house sat for the couple in the past and had a key to their home.
JT和克里斯蒂很快在他们的新社区找到了自己的位置，并在阿什维尔外的一个社区中心结婚。几个月后，他们与亲人分享了克里斯蒂怀孕的消息。当他们发现怀的是个女孩时，他们决定取名为斯凯拉。对于这对新婚夫妇来说，一切都在步入正轨。然而，2015年3月15日星期日，他们的邻居之一塞西莉亚·欧文斯接到了一通电话。是克里斯蒂的父亲从密西西比州的家中打来的。他感到担忧，因为怀孕五个月的克里斯蒂没有做出任何解释就错过了原定的探访。从那以后，他就一直无法联系上她。塞西莉亚·欧文斯过去曾为这对夫妇看管过房子，并有他们家的钥匙。
Christy's father asked Cecilia if she could go over and check on them. As soon as Cecilia arrived on the property, she could tell something was wrong. The couple's cars were parked in the driveway, but when she knocked on the door, nobody answered. Cecilia let herself in. Christie and JT's two pet dogs were inside, but it was clear they hadn't been tended to in a while. Christy typically kept her house in immaculate condition, but the place now stunk. The dogs had defecated and urinated throughout. Cecilia knew Christy would never leave her dogs unattended, as she treated them like her babies. Christy's father called the county sheriff's department and deputies arrived at the couple's
克里斯蒂的父亲问塞西莉亚是否可以过去看看他们。塞西莉亚一到达房产，就感觉到不对劲。这对夫妇的车停在车道上，但当她敲门时，没有人回答。塞西莉亚自己进去了。克里斯蒂和JT的两只宠物狗在里面，但很明显它们已经有一段时间没人照料了。克里斯蒂通常把房子保持得一尘不染，但现在屋里臭气熏天。狗在屋里到处排泄。塞西莉亚知道克里斯蒂绝不会让她的狗无人照看，因为她把它们当作自己的孩子一样对待。克里斯蒂的父亲拨打了县治安官办公室的电话，副警长们抵达了这对夫妇的
home to conduct a welfare check. A cursory search of the home turned up no sign of the couple, but there was evidence of a break-in. Several items appeared to be missing, was evidence of a break-in. Several items appeared to be missing, but Christie and JT's wallets were present, sparking immediate concerns for their wellbeing. More officers arrived to assist with the search, but with the 36-acre property encompassing valleys and mountainous woodland, searching it all would be no easy task. Word quickly spread that 45-year-old JT and 38-year-old Christie were missing, and locals were advised to contact the police with any information pertaining to their whereabouts. At 8.30pm, a call came through from a member of the public who wanted to report something suspicious. On a dead-end street roughly six miles from the Shoen Cobb home, they'd seen a man throwing some
家中进行福利检查。对房屋的初步搜查没有发现这对夫妇的踪迹，但有入室盗窃的迹象。几件物品似乎不见了，但克里斯蒂和JT的钱包还在，这引发了对他们安危的立即担忧。更多的警官赶来协助搜查，但由于这处36英亩的房产包含山谷和多山林地，搜查全部区域绝非易事。45岁的JT和38岁的克里斯蒂失踪的消息迅速传开，当地人被建议联系警方提供任何有关他们下落的信息。晚上8点30分，一名公众打来电话，想要报告一些可疑情况。在距离肖恩-科德家约六英里的死胡同里，他们看到一名男子正在将一些
items into a private residential dumpster. Investigators went to the address and retrieved several garbage bags from the dumpster. Inside were numerous items including a bedspread, handgun, ammunition and jewellery. There was little doubt as to who they belonged to. Not only were these items missing from the Sho and Cob household, among the belongings was Christie's ID. But the biggest breakthrough was that the witness recognised the man they saw dumping the items. 36-year-old Robert Jason Owens. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. At 1.30am on Monday March 16, 2015, police arrived at Jason Owen's home on
物品扔进一个私人住宅垃圾箱。调查人员前往该地址，从垃圾箱中取回了几个垃圾袋。里面有许多物品，包括床罩、手枪、弹药和珠宝。毫无疑问，这些东西属于谁。这些物品不仅是从肖恩-科德家中丢失的，而且在这些财物中还有克里斯蒂的身份证。但最大的突破是，目击者认出了他们看到扔东西的那名男子。36岁的罗伯特·杰森·欧文斯。Casefile稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。2015年3月16日星期一凌晨1点30分，警方抵达了杰森·欧文斯位于
Owens Cove Road. He lived just one mile from Christie and JT's property and was known to the couple. Jason had been one of the first people JT and Christie had met when they moved to the area. Unemployed at the time, he'd accepted JT's offer to help out with some handyman jobs on their property. Extending a hand to those in need was part of JT's nature, as a close friend of his told People magazine, JT was an advocate for every underdog. He really took everybody under his wing who other people weren't willing to give a second look to. Jason Owens got to work clearing trees, building a wellhouse and other such tasks. The ever-trusting JT eventually gave him a key to their storage shed and loaned him $7,000 so he could start his own contracting business.
欧文斯湾路的家中。他住在距离克里斯蒂和JT的房产仅一英里远的地方，并且认识这对夫妇。杰森是JT和克里斯蒂搬到该地区后最早认识的人之一。当时失业的他接受了JT的提议，帮忙在他们的房产上做一些杂工。向有需要的人伸出援手是JT的天性，正如他的一位密友告诉《人物》杂志的那样：“JT是每一个弱势群体的拥护者。他真的把每一个别人不愿意多看一眼的人都置于自己的羽翼之下。”杰森·欧文斯开始清理树木、建造水井房以及做其他类似的工作。一直很信任人的JT最终给了他一把储藏室的钥匙，并借给他7000美元，让他可以开始自己的承包业务。
While his generosity had been admired in Los Angeles, it was exploited in North Carolina. A friend of the couple told People magazine that JT's willingness to help those down on their luck led to people showing up on their doorstep asking for work or money. He described JT as the ATM of the mountains, a reputation that had started to worry Christie. The police placed Jason Owens under arrest for theft and took him to the station for questioning. As reported in the documentary A Good Kid, they had intentionally transported the dumpster to the station and left it in full view for Jason to see upon arrival.
虽然他的慷慨在洛杉矶受到赞赏，但在北卡罗来纳州却被利用了。这对夫妇的一位朋友告诉《人物》杂志，JT帮助那些运气不佳的人的意愿导致人们出现在他们的家门口寻求工作或金钱。他形容JT是“山里的自动取款机”，这种名声已经开始让克里斯蒂感到担忧。警方以盗窃罪逮捕了杰森·欧文斯，并将他带到警局进行审讯。正如纪录片《好孩子》中所报道的那样，他们故意将那个垃圾箱运到警局，并将其放在杰森到达时一眼就能看到的地方。
When he laid eyes on it, his physical reaction indicated he knew that the jig was up. Jason Owens immediately began talking. He told the interviewing detectives that he'd arrived at the Shawang Cod household on Thursday March 12 to help them move JT's vehicle after it had become stuck in a nearby creek. Jason claimed that he got behind the wheel of the Dodge Ram truck and accidentally slammed his foot onto the accelerator. The vehicle sped forward, hitting both JT and Christy who were standing in front of it. According to Jason, he carried the badly injured Christy into the house and placed her in the living room. He tried to administer first aid, but it was no use and she soon passed away. He then went back outside, only to find that JT was already dead. Given that Jason was driving on a suspended licence and was taking medication that left him heavily impaired, he said he panicked at the
当他看到它时，他的身体反应表明他知道大势已去。杰森·欧文斯立即开始说话。他告诉审讯侦探，他于3月12日星期四到达肖恩-科德家，帮助他们移动JT的车辆，因为车陷在附近的一条小溪里。杰森声称他坐进了道奇公羊卡车的驾驶座，不小心猛踩了油门。车辆向前疾驰，撞倒了站在车前的JT和克里斯蒂。据杰森说，他把受重伤的克里斯蒂抱进屋里，放在客厅里。他试图进行急救，但无济于事，她很快就去世了。然后他回到外面，却发现JT已经死了。鉴于杰森是在驾照被吊销的情况下驾驶，并且服用了让他严重受损的药物，他说他因为
prospect of facing more jail time. He took JT's body back to his property, where he burned it in a wood stove. The next day, he returned to the couple's home and dismembered Christie's body in the shower. He then used garbage bags to transport the pieces back to his place and burned those too. Jason claimed he tried to cover the accident up as a robbery gone wrong. He stole some of the couple's belongings and sold them at local flea markets and porn stores, using the money to take his wife out for dinner. Jason also admitted to using Christy's cell phone to send text messages to some of her friends to make it look like she was still alive. The friends who received these messages had been immediately suspicious,
面临更多监禁时间的可能性而惊慌失措。他把JT的尸体带回了自己的房产，用木炉烧掉了。第二天，他回到这对夫妇的家中，在淋浴间肢解了克里斯蒂的尸体。然后他用垃圾袋把尸块运回自己的住处，也把它们烧掉了。杰森声称他试图把这起事故掩盖成一起抢劫未遂案。他偷走了这对夫妇的一些财物，并在当地的跳蚤市场和色情商店卖掉，用这些钱带他的妻子出去吃晚饭。杰森还承认使用克里斯蒂的手机给她的一些朋友发送短信，让看起来她还活着。收到这些短信的朋友立即产生了怀疑，
as the texts didn't sound like Christie at all. Jason Owens reiterated that he didn't mean to hurt JT or Christie, insisting to the detectives, "...I'm not a bad guy. They were two of my best friends. They were. I loved them because they loved me. JT and Christy didn't have friends, they had family. And just like that, I was part of their family. It was true that the couple had treated Jason with nothing but kindness. He'd even attended their wedding, where he stood out to the other guests like a sore thumb. One guest later told People Magazine, "...there was a gut feeling when I looked at this guy and I avoided him. This was one person I definitely did not want to meet."
因为短信听起来根本不像克里斯蒂。杰森·欧文斯重申他不是故意伤害JT或克里斯蒂，并坚持对侦探说：“……我不是个坏人。他们是我最好的两个朋友。他们是。我爱他们，因为他们爱我。”JT和克里斯蒂没有朋友，他们有家人。就这样，我成了他们家庭的一部分。这对夫妇确实对杰森表现得非常友善。他甚至参加了他们的婚礼，在那里他像个异类一样在其他客人中显得格格不入。一位客人后来告诉《人物》杂志：“当我看着这个家伙时，有一种直觉，我避开了他。这是我绝对不想见的一个人。”
one person I definitely did not want to meet. A search of Jason Owen's property turned up enough evidence for police to charge him with two counts of first degree murder and one count of murder of an unborn child. If convicted, he faced the death penalty. Jason was denied bail as the investigation continued. Then, in the early morning hours of Friday March 20, four days after Jason Owens was taken into custody, panicked calls started coming through to 911. One caller told the dispatcher to send fire and law enforcement to Owens Cove Road immediately, exclaiming, somebody is setting fires to everything up here on this mountain. Hurry!
“这是我绝对不想见的一个人。”对杰森·欧文斯房产的搜查发现了足够的证据，警方以两项一级谋杀罪和一项谋杀未出生婴儿罪对他提起诉讼。如果罪名成立，他将面临死刑。随着调查的继续，杰森被拒绝保释。随后，在3月20日星期五凌晨，即杰森·欧文斯被拘留四天后，恐慌的电话开始打入911。一名报警者告诉调度员立即派遣消防和执法部门前往欧文斯湾路，惊呼道：“有人正在山上把这里的一切都点着了。快点！”
First responders arrived at Jason Owens' property to find a mobile home that sat roughly 50 yards from his primary place of residence up in flames. By the time the blaze was extinguished, the entire trailer had been burned to the ground. Arson investigators confirmed that the fire was suspicious, but they wouldn't say what had caused it. Investigators on the Schowen-Cod case declined to confirm whether the wood oven stove Jason used to cremate his victims' remains had been located inside the mobile home. Jason Owens was behind bars at the time of the blaze, which raised the question, who started the fire and why? Theories began to circulate that Jason could have had an accomplice within his family who was trying
急救人员抵达杰森·欧文斯的房产，发现距离他主要住所约50码处的一辆移动房屋陷入火海。当大火被扑灭时，整个拖车已经被烧毁。纵火调查人员证实火灾是可疑的，但他们没有说明起火原因。肖恩-科德案的调查人员拒绝证实杰森用来火化受害者遗体的木炉是否位于那辆移动房屋内。杰森·欧文斯在火灾发生时被关在监狱里，这引发了一个问题：是谁放的火，为什么？开始流传一种理论，即杰森可能在家里有同伙，试图
to destroy evidence. But there was a more pressing question on everyone's lips. With the Jason Owens now charged with murder, what did this mean for the Zeb Quinn investigation? If he was capable of committing one brutal crime, did this also mean he'd committed the other? brutal crime, did this also mean he'd committed the other? The Asheville Police Department confirmed that Jason's arrest was a significant event for their investigation into Zeb's disappearance. In a statement, Zeb's mother Denise asked the public not to overshadow Christy Schellman and JT Codd's heartbreaking deaths with statements, posts and questions about her son. We acknowledge and appreciate the abundant support we have always received from our friends and community and trust you will all give the Cobb-Schowen families the same gift.
销毁证据。但每个人嘴边都有一个更紧迫的问题。随着杰森·欧文斯现在被控谋杀，这对泽布·奎因案意味着什么？如果他有能力犯下一桩残忍的罪行，这是否也意味着他犯下了另一桩？阿什维尔警察局证实，杰森的被捕对于他们调查泽布的失踪案是一个重大事件。在一份声明中，泽布的母亲丹妮丝要求公众不要用关于她儿子的声明、帖子和问题来掩盖克里斯蒂·肖恩和JT·科德令人心碎的死亡。我们承认并感谢我们一直从朋友和社区那里得到的丰富支持，并相信你们所有人都会给科德-肖恩家族同样的礼物。
Denise told reporters for the Asheville Citizen Times that while she viewed the Shoam Cobb murders as totally separate from Zeb's case, quote, I'm hopeful with what Jason Owens is facing, eventually whatever information he may have been holding back, he may decide to go ahead and let it go. But if Jason Owens intended to reveal anything about Zeb's disappearance, someone else beat him to it. Ten days after Jason's arrest, his uncle Gene Owens contacted the police on his own volition. Having heard how his nephew had disposed of JT and Christie's bodies, Jean told the police. Maybe that's what happened to Zeb. Jean told the police that back in 1999 there was an area on Jason Owen's property that Jason had dug out to burn things in, something Jean claimed Jason loved to do. The pit was approximately eight feet long and eight feet wide. Sometime after January 2000,
丹妮丝告诉《阿什维尔公民时报》的记者，虽然她认为肖恩-科德谋杀案与泽布的案子完全分开，但“我希望随着杰森·欧文斯所面临的处境，最终无论他可能隐瞒了什么信息，他都可能决定放手。”但如果杰森·欧文斯打算透露任何关于泽布失踪的消息，有人抢在他前面做了。在杰森被捕十天后，他的叔叔吉恩·欧文斯主动联系了警方。在听说他的侄子是如何处理JT和克里斯蒂的尸体后，吉恩告诉警方：“也许这就是泽布发生的事情。”吉恩告诉警方，早在1999年，杰森·欧文斯的房产上就有一块区域是杰森挖出来烧东西用的，吉恩声称杰森很喜欢这样做。那个坑大约八英尺长，八英尺宽。2000年1月之后的某个时候，
the month that Zeb Quinn went missing, Jason allegedly filled the area with concrete, explaining that he was going to turn it into a fish pond instead. He then abandoned the project and covered the concrete with dirt instead. With that, a warrant was granted for police to search the property for Zeb's remains. Several areas were excavated and the police managed to find fabric, leather materials, unknown hard fragments and several plastic bags filled with white powder. Samples were tested, but they revealed no indication of bone fragments or human remains. Meanwhile, Jason Owens came forward with a story of his own. Jason claimed that his uncle, Gene, was responsible for Zeb's murder and was throwing him under the
即泽布·奎因失踪的那个月，杰森据称用混凝土填满了该区域，解释说他打算把它变成一个鱼塘。然后他放弃了这个项目，改用泥土覆盖了混凝土。至此，警方获得了搜查该房产以寻找泽布遗体的搜查令。几个区域被挖掘，警方设法找到了织物、皮革材料、不明硬碎片和几个装满白色粉末的塑料袋。样本经过了测试，但没有显示出任何骨碎片或人类遗骸的迹象。与此同时，杰森·欧文斯提出了他自己的故事。杰森声称他的叔叔吉恩应对泽布的谋杀负责，并把他推出来做替罪羊，以转移对他自己的注意力。在沉默了15年后，他终于准备好说出关于所发生事情的真相。据杰森说，在2000年1月2日星期日下午，吉恩曾请求他帮个忙。泽布暗恋的米斯蒂·泰勒显然想在不让嫉妒的男友韦斯利·史密斯知道的情况下与泽布见面。吉恩问杰森是否可以带泽布去本溪，那是一片距离阿什维尔市中心约10英里的森林，米斯蒂将在那里露营过夜。杰森照做了。泽布在沃尔玛下班后，两人分乘各自的汽车出发了。据杰森说，当他们到达本溪时，他们发现他的叔叔吉恩停在路边。他们都下了车，泽布问吉恩米斯蒂在哪里。他回答说她马上就到。
bus to deflect attention from himself. After 15 years of silence, he was finally ready to tell the truth about what happened. According to Jason, on the afternoon of Sunday January 2, 2000, Gene had asked him for a favour. Zeb's crush, Misty Taylor, apparently wanted to meet with Zeb without her jealous boyfriend Wesley Smith finding out. Jean asked Jason if he could take Zeb out to Bent Creek, a forest roughly 10 miles from downtown Asheville, where Misty would be camping overnight. Jason did as he was told. After Zeb finished his shift at Walmart, the two headed out in their separate cars. According to Jason, when they got to Bent Creek, they found his uncle Gene parked on the side of the road. They all got out and Zeb asked Jean where Misty was. He responded that she'd be there any minute.
（注：原文此处有重复，已合并）
Zeb turned to keep an eye out, at which point Jason claimed that Jean reached into his truck, took out a.22 calibre rifle, and shot Zeb in the back of the head. In shock and fearing that he could be next, Jason jumped back into his truck. But in his haste to speed off, he crashed into Zeb's car and his head slammed into the steering wheel. Jean ran over and assured Jason he wasn't going to hurt him. Jason asked why he shot Zeb. Jean allegedly responded that Zeb had been putting his nose somewhere he shouldn't be and that someone needed to teach him a lesson. Jean warned Jason not to say a word to anyone, otherwise he'd go down as an accomplice to the murder. Terrified, Jason fled the scene,
泽布转过身去留意，就在这时，杰森声称吉恩伸手进他的卡车，拿出一支.22口径步枪，朝泽布的后脑勺开了一枪。在震惊中，担心自己可能是下一个，杰森跳回了自己的卡车。但在他匆忙逃离时，他撞上了泽布的车，他的头撞在了方向盘上。吉恩跑过来，向杰森保证他不会伤害他。杰森问他为什么要射杀泽布。吉恩据称回答说，泽布把鼻子伸到了他不该伸的地方，有人需要给他一个教训。吉恩警告杰森不要对任何人说一个字，否则他将作为谋杀的同谋被抓。惊恐万分的杰森逃离了现场，
only to return later that night after he couldn't get to sleep. A few hundred yards from the site of the shooting, he claimed he saw a campfire burning. His uncle Gene was tending to it, and Zeb's feet were sticking out of the flames. Gene forced Jason to stay with him overnight, where he continued to feed Zeb's dismembered limbs to the fire. Once his remains were cremated, Jean put out the fire with water from the creek and scattered the ashes in the surrounding forest. Jason was supposed to start work at the Volvo plant at 6am. Their employee policy stated that if a worker didn't show up without calling in
直到那天晚上晚些时候，在他无法入睡后又回到了那里。在距离枪击现场几百码的地方，他声称看到一堆篝火在燃烧。他的叔叔吉恩正在照看它，泽布的脚从火焰中伸了出来。吉恩强迫杰森和他一起过夜，在那里他继续把泽布被肢解的肢体喂给火堆。一旦他的遗体被火化，吉恩就用小溪里的水扑灭了火，并将骨灰撒在周围的森林里。杰森本应在早上6点开始在沃尔沃工厂工作。他们的员工政策规定，如果工人没有提前打电话请假而没有出现，他们就会失去工作。因此，吉恩告诉杰森去急诊室治疗他在撞上泽布的车时受的伤，因为这将给他一个不去上班的正当理由。因为太害怕而不敢说出所发生的事情，杰森声称他把这件事藏在心里15年，一直希望他能告诉泽布的家人关于所发生事情的真相。至于泽布的马自达车重新出现在小猪烧烤餐厅，杰森声称这对他来说和对其他人一样是个谜。
beforehand, they'd lose their job. Jean therefore told Jason to go to urgent care for the injuries he sustained when crashing into Zeb's car, as this would give him a valid reason for not showing up at work. Too scared to speak out about what happened, Jason claimed he kept this to himself for 15 years, all the while wishing he could tell Zeb's family the truth about what happened. As for Zeb's Mazda reappearing at the Little Pigs BBQ restaurant, Jason claimed this was as much of a mystery to him as anyone else. much of a mystery to him as anyone else. While Jason Owens gave this account to police, his uncle Gene Owens was interviewed in another room. Gene had admitted to owning several firearms, most of which were.22 calibre rifles, but he claimed to know nothing about what happened to
（注：原文此处有重复，已合并）
Zeb Quinn. Sensing his nephew might have implicated him, Jean told the detectives that anything Jason Owens said was a lie. Investigators weren't willing to take any chances. They headed out to Bent Creek, a densely vegetated area in Pisgah National Forest known for its network of hiking trails, taking Jason Owens with them. Nothing of interest was found. If Jason's version of events was to be believed, this wasn't surprising given the amount of time that had passed. Investigators remained sceptical. Firstly, the way Jason claimed his uncle had disposed of Zeb's remains bore remarkable similarities to the way he himself had disposed of JT and Christy's
当杰森·欧文斯向警方提供这一陈述时，他的叔叔吉恩·欧文斯正在另一个房间接受采访。吉恩承认拥有几支枪支，其中大部分是.22口径步枪，但他声称对泽布·奎因发生的事情一无所知。感觉到他的侄子可能牵连了他，吉恩告诉侦探，杰森·欧文斯说的任何话都是谎言。调查人员不愿冒险。他们带着杰森·欧文斯前往本溪，那是皮斯加国家森林中一片植被茂密的区域，以其徒步小径网络而闻名。没有发现任何有价值的东西。如果杰森的版本是可信的，考虑到过去的时间，这并不令人惊讶。调查人员仍然持怀疑态度。首先，杰森声称他叔叔处理泽布遗体的方式与他自己处理JT和克里斯蒂尸体的方式有着惊人的相似之处。
bodies. He'd also admitted to posing as Christy in text to her friends, just like he'd been caught doing in the phone call to Walmart just days after Zeb's disappearance. In addition, investigators found inconsistencies in Jason Owen's story that cast doubt on its credibility. They therefore declined to speak with him any further about the matter. But at the same time, some were perplexed by his admission. Jason hadn't asked for anything in exchange for his story, such as leniency of any kind in the Shaw and Cobb murders or immunity in Seb Quinn's case. So if his version of events wasn't true, why make it up? Jason Owen's defence team investigated their client's claims. Jason agreed to undergo a
他还承认在给克里斯蒂朋友的短信中冒充克里斯蒂，就像他在泽布失踪几天后给沃尔玛打电话时被抓到的一样。此外，调查人员在杰森·欧文斯的故事中发现了不一致之处，这使人们对它的可信度产生了怀疑。因此，他们拒绝就此事与他进行进一步交谈。但与此同时，一些人对他的供述感到困惑。杰森并没有要求任何东西来换取他的故事，例如在肖恩-科德谋杀案中获得任何形式的宽大处理，或在泽布·奎因案中获得豁免权。所以，如果他的版本不是真的，为什么要编造它呢？杰森·欧文斯的辩护团队调查了他们当事人的说法。杰森同意接受测谎仪测试，在测试中他坚持自己的故事，即他看着他的叔叔吉恩·欧文斯射杀了泽布·奎因并焚烧了他的遗体。测试没有显示出任何欺骗迹象。根据辩护方发布的文件，警方拒绝披露他们在杰森的故事中发现了什么所谓的矛盾之处，也没有给他机会去解决这些矛盾。辩护团队调查了吉恩·欧文斯的背景，发现他曾可疑地徘徊在泽布·奎因失踪案附近。根据他们的调查结果，当杰森·欧文斯在2002年因高速追逐被捕时，吉恩出现在他的病床边，告诫警方不要问他的侄子任何关于奎因案的问题。辩护方还强调了
polygraph test in which he stuck to his story that he watched his uncle, Gene Owens, shoot Zeb Quinn and burn his remains. The test showed no signs of deception. According to documents released by the defence, the police declined to disclose what alleged inconsistencies they found in Jason's story, nor did they give him a chance to address these inconsistencies. The defence team looked into Gene Owens' background and found that he'd hovered suspiciously close to the Zeb Quinn disappearance. According to their findings, when Jason Owens was arrested for the high-speed chase back in 2002, Gene appeared at his hospital bedside and cautioned the police not to ask his nephew anything about the Quinn matter. The defence also highlighted the
（注：原文此处有重复，已合并）
questionable timing in which Gene Owens came forward with details about the fish pond on the Owens property. Their findings revealed that the so-called fish pond had actually been dug up and turned into a retaining wall years before Zeb's disappearance, information that Jean was well aware of. As far as the defence were concerned, with Jason Owens arrested for the Shaw and Cobb murders, Jean was likely nervous that his nephew would finally be forthcoming with the truth about what happened to Zeb. He therefore crafted the Fishpond story to misdirect the investigation and to further discredit Jason. There was also the lingering question of who set the fire to the trailer on the Owens' property. Jason and Jean had lived on the same property for many years.
吉恩·欧文斯提供关于欧文斯房产上鱼塘细节的时间点非常可疑。他们的调查结果显示，所谓的鱼塘实际上在泽布失踪前几年就已经被挖开并改造成了一堵挡土墙，吉恩对此非常清楚。在辩护方看来，随着杰森·欧文斯因肖恩-科德谋杀案被捕，吉恩很可能很紧张，担心他的侄子最终会说出关于泽布所发生事情的真相。因此，他编造了鱼塘的故事来误导调查，并进一步抹黑杰森。还有一个挥之不去的问题是，是谁在欧文斯的房产上放火烧了拖车。杰森和吉恩多年来一直住在同一处房产上。
Did someone other than Jason know something and feel compelled to destroy evidence? Jason's lawyers defended his decision to remain silent for so long, citing a combination of fear of his uncle and the fear that his story wouldn't be believed, a concern they found valid. According to court documents, a former detective for the Asheville Police Department had confided in one of the defence lawyers, saying, Asheville Police had tunnel vision about the Zep Quinn matter. saying, "...Ashfield police had tunnel vision about the Zeb Quinn matter. They wanted to believe that Jason Owens killed Zeb and they did not want to consider any other possibility." The District Attorney allegedly told the defence team that they were prioritising the investigation
除了杰森之外，还有人知道些什么并感到有必要销毁证据吗？杰森的律师为他长期保持沉默的决定进行了辩护，理由是出于对叔叔的恐惧以及担心他的故事不会被相信，他们认为这种担忧是合理的。根据法庭文件，阿什维尔警察局的一名前侦探曾向其中一名辩护律师吐露心声，称：“阿什维尔警方对泽布·奎因案有隧道视野。他们想相信杰森·欧文斯杀了泽布，他们不想考虑任何其他可能性。”据称，地方检察官告诉辩护团队，他们正在优先调查
into JT and Christie's murders and would address the Quinn matter once the other case was closed. Their main roadblock with the Shoam Cod case was that Jason Owens had done such a thorough job of cremating their remains that investigators couldn't determine how the couple and their unborn child were killed. While they didn't believe a word of Jason's story about the car accident, with no contradicting evidence to suggest otherwise, they felt the version of events he'd given was the closest they'd ever get to knowing what really happened. In April 2017, just over two years after JT, Christy and baby Skylar were killed, Jason Owens accepted a deal. Maintaining the deaths had been
JT和克里斯蒂的谋杀案，并将在另一案件结案后处理奎因案。他们在肖恩-科德案中的主要障碍是，杰森·欧文斯在火化他们的遗体方面做得非常彻底，以至于调查人员无法确定这对夫妇和他们未出生的孩子是如何被杀害的。虽然他们不相信杰森关于车祸的故事的任何一个字，但在没有相反证据的情况下，他们认为他给出的版本是他们所能知道的关于真正发生的事情的最接近的真相。2017年4月，在JT、克里斯蒂和婴儿斯凯拉被杀两年多后，杰森·欧文斯接受了一项协议。他坚持认为死亡是一场
an accident, he pleaded guilty to three counts of second degree murder and two counts of dismembering human remains. In exchange, the death penalty was taken off the table and he was sentenced to a minimum of 59 years and a maximum of 74, without the possibility of parole. A statement released by the District Attorney said, "'Because there are no surviving witnesses and Jason Owens had exclusive control of the crime scene for several days and he had nearly completed the gruesome project of cremating his victims' remains, we will never know many of the facts surrounding the deaths. JT and Christie's loved ones had mixed feelings about the plea deal.
意外，他承认了三项二级谋杀罪和两项肢解人类遗体罪。作为交换，死刑被取消，他被判处至少59年、最多74年的监禁，且不得假释。地方检察官发表的一份声明称：“由于没有幸存的目击者，杰森·欧文斯在几天内独家控制了犯罪现场，并且他几乎完成了火化受害者遗体的可怕工程，我们将永远无法知道围绕这些死亡的许多事实。”JT和克里斯蒂的亲人们对这项认罪协议有着复杂的情绪。
While they were relieved that Jason Owens had been held accountable and would be removed from society, they felt there was no punishment that fit his crime. In a statement, Christie's family said, "...we can only hope that he suffers for the remainder of his life on Earth and again as he rots in hell." Less than two and a half months later, 66-year-old Gene Owens passed away from natural causes. He maintained his innocence in Zeb Quinn's disappearance until the bitter end. Two days later, and allegedly with no warning given to his lawyers, Jason Owens was formally charged with the first degree murder of Zeb Quinn. He maintained that his uncle Gene was the real killer, but with Gene now gone and 17
虽然他们感到欣慰的是杰森·欧文斯已被追究责任并将被从社会中清除，但他们觉得没有任何惩罚能配得上他的罪行。克里斯蒂的家人在一份声明中说：“我们只能希望他在地球上的余生中受苦，并在地狱中腐烂。”不到两个半月后，66岁的吉恩·欧文斯因自然原因去世。他直到最后都坚持自己在泽布·奎因失踪案中是无辜的。两天后，据称在没有事先通知他的律师的情况下，杰森·欧文斯被正式指控犯有一级谋杀泽布·奎因罪。他坚持认为他的叔叔吉恩是真正的凶手，但随着吉恩现在离世，且距离泽布失踪已经过去了17
years passing since Zeb's disappearance, it was Jason's word against the dead man. One key element remained unclear. Gene Owens had no known link to Zeb Quinn, his crush Misty Taylor, or her boyfriend Wesley Smith. As such, Jean had no reason to lure Zeb out to the forest under the guise of having a rendezvous with Misty just to murder him. As revealed in the documentary A Good Kid, Jason claimed to know the missing piece of the puzzle, and that missing piece was a man named Adam Wright. According to Jason, it was Adam Wright who introduced his uncle Gene to Wesley Smith.
年，这成了杰森与死人之间的对质。一个关键因素仍然不清楚。吉恩·欧文斯与泽布·奎因、他暗恋的米斯蒂·泰勒或她的男友韦斯利·史密斯没有任何已知的联系。因此，吉恩没有理由以与米斯蒂幽会为幌子将泽布引诱到森林中去谋杀他。正如纪录片《好孩子》中所揭示的那样，杰森声称知道拼图缺失的一块，而那缺失的一块是一个名叫亚当·赖特的人。据杰森说，正是亚当·赖特将他的叔叔吉恩介绍给了韦斯利·史密斯。
While Jason didn't know the circumstances of their relationship, he assumed that Wesley had told Gene about Zeb's unwanted affection towards Misty. Gene had agreed to remove Zeb from the picture. In a prison interview, Jason told the producers of A Good Kid that the motive had to be money. He said, Gene never told me, but he got something out of it. He wouldn't have done it if he didn't. This story raised one more problem. Adam Wright had passed away from a drug overdose in 2010. There was no one left to vouch for Jason Owen's version of events. Law enforcement remained unconvinced by Jason's assertions, but there was no physical evidence to confirm otherwise. Without something to present to a jury, they knew that securing a murder conviction would be a challenge. Eventually, in July 2022, prosecutors and Dezeb's family agreed to a plea deal.
虽然杰森不知道他们关系的具体情况，但他推测韦斯利告诉了吉恩关于泽布对米斯蒂不想要的爱慕。吉恩同意将泽布从画面中移除。在一次监狱采访中，杰森告诉《好孩子》的制片人，动机一定是钱。他说：“吉恩从来没告诉我，但他从中得到了什么。如果不是这样，他不会这么做的。”这个故事又引发了一个问题。亚当·赖特已于2010年因吸毒过量去世。没有人能为杰森·欧文斯的版本作证。执法部门仍然不相信杰森的断言，但没有实物证据来证实这一点。在没有东西可以提交给陪审团的情况下，他们知道获得谋杀定罪将是一个挑战。最终，在2022年7月，检察官和泽布的家人达成了一项认罪协议。
Jason Owens pleaded guilty to accessory after the fact of first degree murder in exchange for an additional 13 years in prison. The district attorney acknowledged that while many unanswered questions remained, at least the plea brought some form of closure to the Quinn family after over two decades of not knowing for sure if Zeb was alive or dead. In a statement, the district attorney said, "...while we may never know the full truth these many years after Zeb's disappearance, my sympathies are with the family and all who have suffered as a result." Although Misty Taylor and Wesley Smith were questioned by investigators several times over the years, they have never been formally considered persons of interest in Zeb Quinn's disappearance.
杰森·欧文斯承认犯有一级谋杀罪后的从犯罪，以换取额外13年的监禁。地方检察官承认，尽管仍有许多未解之谜，但至少这份认罪协议在奎因一家经历了二十多年不知道泽布是死是活的煎熬后，为他们带来了一种形式上的了结。地方检察官在一份声明中表示：“……虽然在泽布失踪多年后的今天，我们可能永远无法得知全部真相，但我对他的家人以及所有因此受苦的人表示同情。”尽管米斯蒂·泰勒和韦斯利·史密斯多年来多次受到调查人员的盘问，但他们从未被正式列为泽布·奎因失踪案的相关人员。
The mysterious page Zeb received from his aunt's house on the night of his murder has never been explained. Some believe that the police were too focused on Jason Owens from the get-go and that a more resourceful police department could have done a better job of exploring other leads, especially given the many clues left behind in Zerb's abandoned vehicle. Who left the car there and why is a question that will likely never be answered. Jason Owens' lawyer told the documentary A Good Kid, quote, Others believe that Jason Owens is a compulsive liar who acted alone. Whatever the truth, it's a commonly held belief that if Jason hadn't been caught for the murders of JT, Christy and their unborn child, Zeb Quinn's case would likely still be unsolved. Some have
泽布在遇害当晚从他姑姑家收到的神秘传呼至今仍未得到解释。一些人认为，警方从一开始就过于关注杰森·欧文斯，如果警察部门更有能力，本可以更好地探索其他线索，特别是考虑到泽布被遗弃的车辆中留下了许多线索。是谁把车停在那里的，为什么要这样做，这个问题可能永远不会有答案。杰森·欧文斯的律师在纪录片《一个好孩子》中说道，引用如下。其他人则认为杰森·欧文斯是一个惯于撒谎的人，他是单独行动的。无论真相如何，人们普遍认为，如果杰森没有因JT、克里斯蒂及其未出生孩子的谋杀案而被捕，泽布·奎因的案件很可能至今仍未侦破。一些人
criticised the courts for accepting Jason Owen's plea deals in both cases. Given that prosecutors didn't fully believe his version of events, it raises the question of whether or not justice has truly been served for his victims. Christy's family are convinced that Jason didn't act alone in JT and Christy's deaths either. In their statement after his plea deal was accepted, they said, "...although we know deep down that others in his family hold responsibility for these heinous murders, there is not much we can do in terms of justice for them. We will attempt to heal and let go of some of the anger that we still have. We also have to say that we are so lucky to have met some of the most wonderful people through this
批评法院接受了杰森·欧文斯在两起案件中的认罪协议。鉴于检察官并不完全相信他的供述，这引发了一个问题：他的受害者是否真正得到了正义的伸张。克里斯蒂的家人确信，杰森在JT和克里斯蒂的死亡事件中也不是单独行动的。在他们的认罪协议被接受后的声明中，他们说：“……虽然我们内心深处知道他家里的其他人也应对这些令人发指的谋杀案负责，但在正义方面我们能做的并不多。我们将尝试治愈并放下我们仍然怀有的一些愤怒。我们还必须说，我们非常幸运，通过这场
tragedy. Those people are the family of Zeb Quinn. This family deserves just as much healing, peace, and closure as we do, and we can only hope they get a little bit of that." The Quinn family asked for privacy in the wake of Jason Owen's plea deal, but at his hearing, Zeb's mother Denise spoke about her son's belief that you should always try to see the best in people. She reflected on a time when Zeb was in high school and she wasn't happy about some of the people he chose to hang around with. Denise warned her son that he would be judged by the company he kept. She told the court, quote, Zeb looked back at me and said,
悲剧结识了一些最棒的人。这些人就是泽布·奎因的家人。这个家庭和我们一样，理应得到治愈、平静和了结，我们只能希望他们能得到一点点慰藉。”奎因一家在杰森·欧文斯达成认罪协议后要求保护隐私，但在听证会上，泽布的母亲丹妮丝谈到了她儿子的一种信念，即你应该总是试着看到人们最好的一面。她回忆起泽布上高中时，她对他选择交往的一些人感到不满。丹妮丝警告儿子，他会因为他所交往的人而受到评判。她告诉法庭，引用如下，泽布回头看着我说，
They have done nothing wrong to me and have done nothing wrong around me and I will continue to be their friend. This is the young man that was taken from his family, friends, community and the world. This is a young man that never would have seen his end coming. This is the young man who trusted his friend, Jason. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他们没有对我做任何错事，也没有在我身边做任何错事，我将继续做他们的朋友。这就是那个被从他的家人、朋友、社区和世界中夺走的年轻人。这是一个永远不会预见到自己结局的年轻人。这是一个信任他的朋友杰森的年轻人。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。